إليزابيث ، صباح الخير لك ، هناك
عدد من العوامل المعقدة هنا
بالنسبة
للرئيس البالغ من العمر 74 عامًا ، فهو من الناحية الفنية
يعتبر
سمينًا من حيث وزنه وهذا
يأتي مع زيادة
المخاطر ، وهناك أيضًا أشياء لا
نعرفها عن تاريخه الطبي
كيف  في خطر هو أن الرئيس
هناك الكثير مما لا نعرفه عن
تاريخه الطبي الخشخاش ، فلنستعرض
عوامل الخطر تلك التي
ذكرتها للتو مرة أخرى
حيث ذكرت أنه يبلغ من العمر 74 عامًا ، لذا
فهو مسن في المجموعة الأكثر
خطورة من قبل  عمره يزن 244 رطلاً
مما يجعله بدينًا سريريًا
، وقد عولج من ارتفاع الكوليسترول
في وقت ما تناول هيدروكسي كلوروكوين
عندما
تعرض لموظف آخر في البيت الأبيض كان مطمئنًا ،
ولا نعرف ما إذا كان قد استمر في تناوله
أم أنه بدأ  أخذها مرة أخرى
الآن أريد أن أؤكد أن هذا بالتأكيد
يضعه في فئة عالية الخطورة للغاية من
كبار السن وبدين إكلينيكيًا وهو أيضًا
ذكر وهذا لا يساعد أيضًا ولكن
سأقول  أن معظم الناس ،
حتى لو كانوا في هذه الفئة الأكثر خطورة
، يعيشون ويتعاملون مع مرض covid19 بشكل جيد ، لذلك من
المهم أن نتذكر
أن مخاطره أعلى بالتأكيد من الآخرين
ولكن لا يزال معظم الناس بخير
[الموسيقى]
يطلعونا على البروتوكول الآن  بالنسبة
لاختبار كوفيد إيجابي عندما يتعلق الأمر
بالعزلة ، أعتقد أن هذه هي الكلمة الصحيحة
هنا كم من الوقت
يجب أن يظل الرئيس بعيدًا عن
الاتصال الآن مع الآخرين لمنع نقل
العدوى إليهم بشكل صحيح ، ويعتمد ذلك على ما إذا
كان يعاني من أعراض أم لا ، لذلك دعونا نلقي
نظرة
على ماذا  هذه القواعد هي أنه في حالة ظهور أعراض على شخص ما ،
يجب
عزله لمدة 10 أيام بعد
تحسن الأعراض بعد
ظهور الأعراض بدلاً من ذلك ، ويجب أن
تتحسن أعراضه خلال تلك الفترة دون أن تزداد
سوءًا
ويجب أن يكون عمره 24 ساعة بدون
حمى ، لذلك كل هؤلاء الثلاثة  يجب
أن تحدث الأشياء
بالنسبة له للخروج من العزلة الآن
إذا لم تظهر عليه أي أعراض إذا كان على ما
يرام تمامًا
، فيجب أن يبقى في عزلة لمدة 10
أيام بعد أن كان يعاني من ذلك.  اختبار إيجابي
إذا كان الأمر كذلك ، ونأمل ألا يكون الأمر كذلك إذا
أصيب بمرض شديد ،
فهذه القواعد كلها معطلة ، عليك
استشارة الطبيب لتقرير ما
يجب فعله في هذه الحالة ،
تساعدنا إليزابيث في فهم ماهية
الاتصال الوثيق لجميع هؤلاء  الناس
وكان هناك الكثير منهم كما
أفاد جون بأنهم كانوا حول
الرئيس في الأيام القليلة الماضية
ناهيك عن مرشحة المحكمة العليا
إيمي كومي باريت التي التقت به مع
جميع أطفالها وكذلك في البيضاوي يوم
السبت
ماذا يفعل  الاتصال الوثيق يعني إلى أي
مدى ومدى القرب
من القرص المضغوط يحدده الخشخاش على وجه التحديد ، دعنا نلقي نظرة ، فهذا يعني أنك كنت على بعد ستة أقدام من شخص مصاب بفيروس كوفيد
لمدة 15 دقيقة أو أكثر الآن
الفترة الزمنية التي ننظر فيها إلى الوراء  قبل يومين
من ظهور الأعراض ، إذا
لم تظهر عليك الأعراض مطلقًا ،
فقبل يومين من حصولك على هذا
الاختبار الإيجابي ، فما
الذي يجب أن يفعله العاملون في مجال الصحة العامة
الآن
هو رسم مخطط من  كان
الرئيس على اتصال
به خلال تلك الفترة الزمنية ، ثم
يجب عليهم الاتصال بكل هؤلاء الأشخاص
ومطالبتهم بالحجر الصحي